okay I've got kind of a I don't like the
bum people out but I do like to tell you
what's going on earlier this week i
explained to you that as a result of
patreon shifting around how they handled
the fees on donations through that
platform the David Pakman show fund
raises through patreon at patreon.com
slash david pakman show patreon decided
to shift some of the burden of the fees
on the platform towards the donor and
away from the recipient and this was a
disastrous idea from patreon partially
because it was a bad idea to begin with
and additionally because it was messaged
terribly and it led to nearly 200
patrons canceling their contributions to
the David Pakman show I got a voicemail
saying David do you see what people are
saying on your video about the patreon
situation here's that voicemail that
came in
hi David this is Tim I just wanted to
say that I think it's really [ __ ] up
how you been getting defunded left and
right so I just became a member and then
I saw your video called patreon is
killing us and oh my goodness I saw all
those comments was really mean like I
know that there's a lot of useful trolls
out there but damn do you have a lot of
YouTube troll so I wanted to say for you
and Pat to the hater thank you doing
what you're doing
and good luck after we received this
voicemail I said you know it's been so
busy I haven't even seen the comments on
that YouTube video about the problems
we're having with patreon and it's
absolutely vile and disgusting people
are jumping for joy proverbially over
the problems we're having with patreon
funding I'll put just a couple of these
comments up on the screen for you one
user called seeking truth 2014 Wow Wow I
don't want to get a real job
wow what a nuanced and productive
critique of the problem we're having
pretty sure this is a real job - I
thought it was I thought it was if my
accountant has been tricked all this
time into thinking that I'm actually
working then I really have to apologize
to him also haha David cockman ship is
sinking another user on YouTube still
begging for money get a job scum
bag yeah that comes up a lot that this
isn't a real job okay this is your
business it has employees this is this
is what we do I get up in the morning
put my pants on three legs at a time and
come in here you know that's what we
love I think that's what they're jealous
of absolutely right
also haha glad David Pakman is failing I
think we've got one or two more here
maybe not one more good I hope you're
centrist pro corporate pro military
intervention pro-russia hysteria and
throw apartheid channel gets wiped out
same thing happened when we announced
that our Amazon affiliate link had been
turned off I mean just totally canceled
and two months of revenue would not be
paid to us people rejoicing rejoicing in
the streets Trump incorrectly claimed
that like thousands of people in New
Jersey were cheering 9/11 or something
like that we actually have the real
evidence that when we lost our Amazon
link and patreon made this change which
really hurt us there were hundreds and
hundreds of people on the internet
rejoicing that we'll have proof of but I
mean we can't let the hatreds win here
that we can't do no absolutely not I'm
hoping that there are more good people
that are silent and are contributing and
that they sort of overpower these scum
that want us to fail